hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my x-men apocalypse Easter eggs
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the movie yet I'll also be talking about
the post-credits scene - at least we can
all agree that the third one is always
the worst so let's just start with a
really big one first The Return of the
Jedi Easter Egg so they come out of the
movie theater in the mall you've never
been to a mall oh that's it we're going
to the mall so Jubilee comes out and
says a Empire so much better which has
been one of the biggest nerd debates of
all time with the best Star Wars movie
is then Cyclops says the second one's
always the best before Jean Grey is like
yet the third one at least we can all
agree the third one's always the worst
this is both Bryan Singer patting
himself on the back for x2 as well as
Days of Future past which I think of the
two best x-men films of all time not
including the spin-offs like Deadpool
but by saying the third one is always
the worst they're making fun of x3 one
of the worst x-men films of all time but
they're also taking the piss out of
themselves a little like Bryan Singer
saying x-men apocalypse is also one of
the worst x-men films of all time so
just a really awesome well-written meta
joke total slam-dunk but let's talk
about the post credit sequence if you're
not familiar with the Essex Corp that is
Nathaniel Essex mr. sinister meaning
that he's probably going to be the main
villain of the next film but that's not
even the biggest thing so everybody
knows Hugh Jackman has said that he's
only doing the last Wolverine movie and
then that'll pretty much be it for him
he's not going to be the character
anymore as a result you probably won't
be surprised to hear that Bryan Singer
has already pitched x-23 to Fox
executives and it sounds like they're
totally on board with it because they
take his blood sample his Weapon X blood
sample and it sounds like they're going
to clone him and that's why the next
movie's going to be in the 90s so we'll
get to see a version of x-23 who is a
female clone of Wolverine she takes over
for Wolverine in the comics after he
ends up dying it's a whole big comic
book story that has nothing to do with
what's going on in the movies but she
ends up taking the mantle of Wolverine
so it sounds like they're gonna try and
do that in the movies too
what you think it'll be a lot of fun
hopefully they'll get someone that's
totally badass but they haven't talked
about casting they haven't even said how
she's going to be involved in the next
couple of movies but we can talk more
about her later a lot of you had
questions about the timeline changes how
did Stryker get Wolverine into Weapon X
if mystique saved him at the end of Days
of Future past so you may have detected
some continuity problems in the
that's essentially them just kind of
waving their hand they did that on
purpose they're ignoring their own
continuity just a little bit because
they wanted that really awesome
Wolverine moment they wanted to show him
after Weapon X so they just said screw
the timeline we're gonna put Wolverine
in there we're gonna do Weapon X let's
do it and Wolverine is wearing his
helmet from Weapon X so Wolverine
himself like the way he comes out the
way he looks is a big Easter Egg for his
original comic book look and you may
have noticed that with some of the
costumes especially at the end we're
mystique and the rest of the x-men are
all wearing their traditional colors
it's like updated versions that look
very much like the comic book costumes
they even give Cyclops the visor and
they have the Danger Room now which is a
nice Easter Egg for the comics and
speaking of mr. sinister he actually
became who he is because of apocalypse
obviously they're going to have to
retcon some of that for the movies
because the movie is saying that
apocalypse got buried for all this time
so he hasn't been around but the other
really cool thing about him is that he
is responsible for the birth of cable
mr. sinister is obsessed with bloodlines
and genetic tampering I'm not really
expecting the movies to address that
there might be some Easter eggs in the
next deadpool movie because cable is
going to be in the deadpool sequel you
may have spotted Stanley's cameo during
the big dr. Strangelove sequence I felt
like the bunker was very dr. Strangelove
looking but Stanley naturally looking up
as the world's about to end with his
wife who is his real-life wife that's
actually his real-life wife in the movie
we get a bald professor Eck's by the end
of the movie we get our tease for the
Phoenix force not yet Dark Phoenix yet
it doesn't become dark Phoenix until the
Phoenix fully takes over Jean Grey so
there's Phoenix and then there's Dark
Phoenix but I think we're all in
agreement that they're definitely
pushing into a Dark Phoenix saga movie
eventually whether they turn that into a
couple movies or they try to do it as a
single movie hopefully they try to tease
that out a little bit you don't go
straight from Jean Grey learning about
her powers in school as a young girl to
Dark Phoenix she doesn't become Dark
Phoenix till much later in her life
Moira MacTaggert comes back no longer
married but she does have a son on the
animated series she had a son named
Proteus that was one of the villains the
blob is back we haven't seen him since
Wolverine Origins beast builds the x-jet
and the underground basketball court
hangar that they mentioned during
x2 and on top of that there's more x2
callbacks I mean it's a Bryan Singer
film so core she's going to include a
lot of references to his previous x-men
films but there's a Professor X line of
dialogue that James McAvoy borrows
directly from Patrick Stewart's version
of the character where he says I feel a
great swell of pity for the poor soul
that comes to this school looking for
trouble that's a line directly from x2
visually there are a lot of Easter eggs
for the movies we have Mohawk storm from
the 80s which is such an amazing look
for her Nightcrawler is wearing Michael
Jackson's Thriller jacket through most
of the movie there are a couple deep cut
Morlock characters like Caliban we
haven't seen the Morlocks in a long time
they were a big part of the animated
series they changed apocalypse as powers
a little bit for the movie but they give
us growing apocalypse when they're
fighting inside the mine palace a lot of
people are wondering if Magneto's
daughter that winds up dying in the
movie is a version of Scarlet Witch you
can think of her that way but it's so
confusing as to the arrangement with
Marvel I think they have to tiptoe
around their relationship in the comics
but it does sound like they're pushing
forward with Quicksilver father-son
relationship when apocalypse goes to
recruit angel turn him in to Archangel
his arc Angel of Death
Metallica's Four Horseman is playing on
the PA system when he's learning about
the world by watching TV one of the
programs is old-school Star Trek in an
episode that's actually called who
mourns for Adonai and it's the story
about how they encounter the Supreme
Being calling himself Apollo that's a
lot like Apocalypse
so yeah pocalypse already felt like a
god to begin with but I think he sees
this and just chuckles to himself a
little bit he does have a sense of humor
but it doesn't really come across that
much in the movie the only real spin-off
Easter egg that I could detect was x-23
x-force because she's a big x-force
character mr. sinister is an x-men
proper character he appeared in uncanny
x-men for the first time but there's a
lot of villain crossover when you get to
these other titles like x-force Deadpool
New Mutants so they'll probably be
sharing a lot of characters eventually
in Bryan Singer did say there's a lot of
deleted scenes so there'll be more
Easter eggs when they release those but
one of the biggest ones is that Taylor
Swift is Dazzler so when they're at the
mall there was this deleted scene where
they're flipping through records and
jean grey pulls one out in its Daz
letter but it's Taylor Swift as Dazzler
on this album and on top of that more
most
if jubilee actually uses her powers in
this mall sequence but Brian singer
confirmed that it got left on the
cutting room floor but if you guys
spotted any other big Easter eggs that I
didn't mention in the video just write
them below in the comments so what I'm
probably going to do in a couple days is
do another x-men video for the next
sequel I'll talk about Dark Phoenix I'll
talk about mr. sinister stuff I'll talk
about x-force a little bit especially
x-23 really excited about that so be
sure to subscribe to get that I'm also
working on a preacher video there's new
Game of Thrones this weekend and I'll
start doing some more Marvel videos now
that a lot of DC TV has gone away so
while you guys wait for that next video
to post you can click here for my x-men
apocalypse review and you can click here
for my Captain America number one WTF
reaction thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
hail Hydra